if your in spin and anti- spin is coming
along at least a bit and you've put some
time into having fairly clear pfu
meaning your hands past Center of your
imaginary Circle together and your hands
pass each other quite closely on either
side then you can start putting it all
together as in spin and anti- spin Wall
playing split time opposites flower
patterns definitely easier to start in
in
spin there's a really important
consideration you can make here uh and
that's whether both POI pass inside your
arms or whether you've only got one POI
inside I I do more often only one Po in
between my arms I find it's easier to
switch to antipin that way but I
recommend exploring both I'm doing it as
you can see with one po outside my
arm and in spin my arms are going to
circle the same direction as the PO and
at first you can really take your time
just make sure you got good po Fu that
the hands stay one above the other they
pass the center together and the hands
pass each other quite closely on the
outside of the circle on the
sides as that starts to work you can
start speeding up to pattern and a great
place to get is where you do one ins
spin ins spin ins spin on each Cardinal
so an ins spin at the side top and
bottom side top and bottom now the ins
spins are nice because it's visually
very easy to see whether you've truly
got one Circle above the other one in
the middle because you can see whether
the PO kind of brush
noses it's a lot harder to see whether
you've got that if the are away it
becomes all the more important to use a
mirror but you'll need both so a great
place to first start is meeting in the
middle middle middle middle middle
middle middle middle middle and and
especially if you can find a way to get
a mirror you can work on the outs now I
find it awkward and kind of weird to go
out out
out so what I do is once uh I've got the
cardinal the ins spins and the Cardinals
all dialed in I switch to either ins
spins at the side swoop the side swoop
the side swoop the side or put the ins
spins at top and bottom and swoop
through the sides swoop swoop middle
swoop middle swoop middle swoop middle
swoop middle we can call this pattern
vertical in spins and this pattern
horizontal in spins once ins spin is
Roll Along smoothly and you're beginning
to see whether you're hitting the
Cardinals clearly you can do anti- spin
I recommend once again starting really
slow and just
noticing whether your hands are one
above the other whether the circles are
really meeting up symmetrically in the
middle and whether your hands are
passing close to each other on these
sides because a lot of people tend to do
this and it typically doesn't look as
nice um I bet what you like seeing is
when you get these nice metrical flower
patterns where you can really see a
clover and that is where the Precision
of the pfu is important so first slowly
slowly
slowly now eventually you speed it up
where they pass in the middle they touch
you know they're in the center of circle
at the top and bottom also at the side
top and bottom side and it goes boom
boom boom top and bottom side top and
bottom side top and bottom side top and
bottom side once again coming back to
noticing whether your P Fu was good
because that really helps a lot and uh
when you've got that do the inverse
which is where the PO point away on each
Cardinal away away away away away away
away away and the PO Fu will really help
boom boom boom boom boom boom the in
spin will come quicker than the anti-
spin that's normal this stuff for almost
everybody takes weeks or months to
really uh to really master so you're
probably doing fine if it seems to be
going
slow and for all of this you can play
with one POI being inside the arms on
the sides or both po being in between
the arms on the sides I I find it's
having one outside there's a few things
that will come more naturally especially
when we get into
switchbacks so give yourself a month or
two to really dial all this in or even
more eventually it's all going to flow
um but some people really uh
underestimate how much time it takes to
get clear po
flowers so next video we'll start
looking in making weird combinations
combining ins spins and anti spins and
eventually we'll play with going through
um switchbacks
of patterns all inter
locking Nichol the reporting from
leviath in Studio which is an amazing
place and you should join us here for
next year's Leviathan po Retreat these
are pod Po and uh do visit play.com
sometimes I've got a gear section it's
podp inside speeder super socket in the
outside I review the gear I like it
gives you a way to save money while
supporting me and helping me justify all
the time it takes to make these
videos ha I said everything I think
[Music]
n